NATALIE KENT: Welcome.
My name is Natalie Kent.
And I'm a sophomore here
studying English and French.
I'm here this evening to
introduce our new speaker, Dr.
Mark Blitz.
Mark Blitz is the
Fletcher Jones Professor
of Political Philosophy at
Claremont McKenna College.
He earned his AB and PhD
from Harvard University.
Prior to his appointment
at Claremont McKenna,
he taught political philosophy
at Harvard University
and the University
of Pennsylvania.
He served in the
Reagan administration
as Associate Director of the
United States Information
Agency, where he was
the senior United States
official in charge of
educational and cultural
programs abroad.
Dr. Blitz has also
served as a senior staff
member of the Senate
Committee on Foreign Relations
and as vice president
of the Hudson Institute.
He is the author of
numerous books titled
Conserving Liberty, Plato's
Political Philosophy, Duty
Bound--
Responsibility and
American Public Life,
and Heidegger's "Being and
Time" and the Possibility
of Political Philosophy.
Ladies and gentlemen, please
welcome Dr. Mark Blitz.
[APPLAUSE]
MARK BLITZ: Thanks, Natalie
for that nice introduction.
I once worked in government
for someone very controversial.
And whenever he gave
a speech and received
a nice introduction, he
would look around and say,
I must be in the wrong room.
[LAUGHTER]
But I'm in the right room.
And thank you all
for being here.
I don't pretend to be
an expert on Confucius,
although I've
taught his Analects.
But it's not
completely unreasonable
that I'm talking
to you about him.
My area academically is
political philosophy,
specifically Plato and
Aristotle, but also
19th- and 20th-century
German philosophy.
And it turns out that
Aristotle and Plato
are very good jumping-off
points for us in order
to understand and
consider Confucius.
As Natalie mentioned, I
was also, at one point--
this was during Ronald
Reagan's second term--
in charge of our country's
Academic and Young Leader
exchange programs, the Fulbright
Program, and other programs
similar to that, and
also of our books
and libraries and
foreign cultural centers,
kind of the US
equivalent of what
China now has abroad with
all of its Confucius centers,
these centers which
they've started
in various universities,
to some degree
for propagandistic
purposes, to some degree
to keep tabs on students.
But in general, we didn't
do any such things.
The point of our US
programs was what was then
called mutual understanding.
Now they call it soft power.
We actually thought of it
during the Reagan administration
as the war of ideas--
the war of ideas,
freedom, capitalism,
liberal democracy on one side,
communism on the other side.
So I was, as it were,
an officer in this war
and therefore have
considered something
about the effect of thought
on a people as a whole,
something relevant obviously
to Confucius and China.
Obviously, in a way,
the war of ideas
never ends, as we see
today, even if one prevails
for a while, as we did.
But it's a continuing
and ongoing effort.
So Confucius, or more
literally Master Kong--
wonderful name--
lived, they think--
because these things are always
a bit hazy, off a year or two,
lived--
let's say, from 551 to 479 BC.
His family was nobility.
But he was himself not wealthy.
And he always referred
favorably to the Zhou Dynasty,
which ruled his home state,
which was in Northern China.
This rule was breaking
down during his life.
He had various minor political
positions, never really
a major one, although it
seems that he and his students
wanted major positions.
That was one of his
goals, not achieved.
And for long periods of time he
was just an itinerant teacher.
The facts of his life are
hazy because reports of them
are not really contemporaneous.
They occur much later.
Most important for us, the
status of the Analects,
which is the central compilation
of his views, the status
of the Analects, as a
text, as we scholars say,
is very unclear.
The present text was compiled
by a much later scholar.
Which sayings were
written or said by him
or were compiled from
things he actually
said, who knows for sure.
So it would be very hard
to study the Analects
with a kind of precision with
which one would study a novel,
or even one of the works of
Plato, where you can be certain
that the author wrote the thing,
and you can study the work as
if it reflects the
intention of the author.
Unclear when you study
Confucius that you
can do something like that.
So scholars try to resolve
these uncertainties
by considering what was
handed down after his death
and then dismissing what seems
historically anachronistic.
The Analects are composed
of 20 books, a bunch of what
are called chapters
in each books,
but the chapters are just these
short sayings, by and large.
Books 3 through 9 and
11 through 15 of the 20
are generally considered
to be authentic,
and books 4 through 8 are
thought to be the oldest.
But these, I think,
are thoughts,
and no one knows certainly.
So this uncertainty,
as I said, really
affects the precision with
which anyone can study him.
Now, Confucius is
significant first
because his thought
or his statements
and those of his disciples
have become so important
in China and in the
countries influenced by it.
And second, of course,
he's significant because
of the content of
the thought itself.
His work went through
various stages of influence.
It became significant,
especially during the dynasty
which began to
rule China in 960.
This was when the civil service
examinations that were based
on Confucius really took hold.
This importance of
Confucius and commentaries
on Confucius for the civil
service examinations, which
helped to rise to the top,
this went on until 1905.
So Confucius's great
influence comes first
from the fact that in
order to make your career
and keep your way, you had
to know him for the exams,
and second, because much
of that seeped down.
Much of what he said then
seeped down to ordinary views.
So even when Mao Zedong
attacked Confucius and Confucian
thinking, which he did,
this didn't really, I think,
take hold because of
the historic influence
and power of the thought.
You might think here,
to a much lesser extent,
but nonetheless of the British
Civil Service in its heyday,
let's say, from the last half or
last third of the 19th century
until the Cold War, when
everyone, pretty much, who
went to the schools from
which senior people were drawn
knew the Greek and
Latin classics.
And some knew them very well.
Or you might consider the
upper crust of the French Civil
Service, where they all
study, and they still
study Descartes and the
Enlightenment and so on.
And the upper crust of
these civil services
are extremely important
in running the country.
Confucius expresses the point
of this kind of education.
Rather than a merely
technical education, in one
of his remarks--
let me read it--
"the master said--"
wouldn't it be
wonderful to have
before anything
you said "the master said?"
"The master said, a gentleman
does not behave as a tool"
The education is not merely an
education to be an implement
or a tool for someone
else, but it's
to be the kind of education
to lead and govern.
So I mentioned at the
beginning, the likeness
that people sometimes
see to Aristotle
and why Plato and Aristotle
are a good jumping-off point
for understanding Confucius.
And I'll begin my discussion of
the substance of the Analects
by saying what, compared
to Aristotle, it is not.
What's the difference?
And I think that'll help
us to place the Analects
intellectually or
philosophically in relation
to something more familiar.
Compared to Aristotle,
there's no development
of practical reason.
There's no development
of the elements
of practical reasoning.
Nor is there a defense
of intellectual reason,
or what Aristotle calls
intellectual virtue.
As such, there's no defense of
unbridled philosophical inquiry
of the sort one sees in book
10 of Aristotle's Ethics
or in Plato and in The
Republic, in particular.
Compared to Aristotle, there's
also no systematic discussion
of the elements of justice
or the elements of happiness
or of the virtues
or even friendship.
There's lots of
discussion of some
of those things, but no
systematic discussion.
By that I mean not only
that matters aren't
traced to some ontological
or metaphysical foundation,
they're not.
But they're not really in
Aristotle either in the Ethics.
I mean that.
But I also mean that the
varieties and alternatives
of virtue, justice, happiness,
are not systematically
traced and categorized,
as Aristotle does.
Compared to Aristotle,
there's also
no discussion really
of the human soul
and the powers and
abilities of the human soul.
Even Aristotle's elementary
discussion in the Ethics,
let alone Plato's
discussion of the powers
of the soul in The Republic, or
both of their more fundamental
discussions in other works.
Compare it to John
Locke, in a way, one
of the great intellectual
founders behind the Declaration
of Independence.
Compared to John
Locke, there are
in Confucius no
individual rights,
no individual natural rights, no
tracing of political authority
to natural individual
authority, no opening up
of property to full,
private acquisition,
and no true consent
of the governed.
There's little valuing
of competition.
"The master said,
there's nothing
which gentlemen compete over.
If competition were inevitable,
it would be in archery,
wouldn't it?
But they go up bowing and
making way for each other.
And when they come
down, they have a drink.
So even in their
competition with each other,
they are gentlemen."
No real competition argued
for is a good thing,
in a manner similar to ours.
In terms of what Confucius
does emphasize in these books
but is not discussed
in Aristotle,
one obvious difference is
Confucius's emphasis on ritual,
on custom, on forms of dress,
on manners, one might say.
There's nothing at all in
the Ethics of Aristotle
or in his other
works that's really
like book 10 of the
Analects of Confucius,
which is where a lot of this
discussion of ritual occurs.
So because of all
of these facts,
the discussions in Confucius
or the sayings in Confucius
often seem more like
exhorting, hortatory statements
of the sort that you
might occasionally even
find in elements of
Plato's dialogues.
Before then, Plato
and Socrates dig
into the real meaning and
intellectual substance
of those issues.
The Analects are
really about how
to follow a way, how to follow
a traditional way, in terms
of what he thinks
is best in that way,
and given whatever choices
are still open to it.
All of that said, lots of
what he recommends that you do
are, I think, what we
would also recommend.
To fully explore the
substance of the Analects
would require a lengthy study.
But I can at least
indicate, I think,
the major terms,
the major guidelines
of Confucius's thought.
I put it this way in
terms of guidelines,
because the Analytics,
as I just indicated,
are about how to behave,
but in particular, they're
about how to behave
generally if you
have or aspire to a particular
role or a particular station.
They're not based on
universal individualism,
where everything is, in
principle, open to everyone.
They're not really based on
the kind of behavior which is,
in principle, open to everyone.
But they're very much
tied to particular roles,
particular status.
In addition to
considering the Analects
by thinking about
its major guidelines,
one should also see that
Confucius's remarks are often
directed to
particular disciples.
They're a group of
disciples with whom
he has these discussions
in the Analects,
and they're different.
There are particular
qualities, particular limits
that are mentioned in
the Analects itself.
So it's not always
clear if a given remark
is meant to be generally
applicable, as it might seem,
or more particularly applicable
to the one to whom it's
being addressed.
So given it all this,
what are the major terms
or major thoughts?
There's first the key
human type, the key
or central human type
that he recommends,
the gentleman, as opposed
to the petty or small man.
That's the difference.
To read a couple of
things, "Ji Kang-zi asked
Master Kong about
government, saying,
suppose I were to kill those
who lack the way in order
to advance those
who have the way.
How would that be?
Master Kong replied, you
are running the government.
So what is the point of killing?
If you desire good, the
people will be good.
The nature of the
gentlemen is as the wind,
and the nature of a small
man is as the grass.
When the wind blows over
the grass, it always bends."
So this is among, of course,
his famous sayings on which you
could reflect for a long time.
To read something
else about gentlemen,
which he says, "the
master said, the gentleman
reaches out for what is above.
The small man reaches
out for what is below."
You'd rather be a
gentleman, of course.
There are also
people he calls men
of quality, those who
have particular virtues,
particular skills,
those he calls sages,
who have a certain
level of learning even
beyond the gentleman.
There's further what he
once calls the complete man.
All of these are high
or desirable types,
and it's the gentleman
who's most fully described.
He also discusses the
people who are governed,
various levels of
government officials.
There's very little
on women, by the way.
And the major
statement about women
would be politically
incorrect for us now.
[LAUGHTER]
I therefore won't
read it to you.
[LAUGHTER]
Now, gentlemen are supposed
to embody or exemplify
a characteristic which,
is called ren, R-E-N, when
it's transliterated and so on.
That's the central quality.
It's often translated as
humaneness or humanity,
sometimes translated
as generosity.
Benevolence might be better, or
perhaps kind of graciousness,
propriety, refinement.
You might say it's the
gracious ease or propriety that
in the past used to define the
gentleman, not just his past,
but our past as well.
You might call this
graciousness or humaneness,
the broad substance of virtuous
action in regard to others.
One reason that graciousness
or benevolence, in a way,
is a useful translation, maybe
more than humaneness simply,
is because this quality
is not something, I think,
characteristic of all human
beings, as Confucius sees it.
Again, it's most likely
the graceful ease
and propriety of the
gentleman, in particular.
To be humane--
I'll use that term--
is not to be rude or
coarse or devious.
"The master said, when substance
prevails over refinement,
there's churlishness.
And when refinement
or mere refinement
prevails over substance,
there is pedantry.
Only if refinement and
substance are properly blended
does one become a gentleman."
Now, next point,
really, the virtues
or humaneness or
benevolence, generally,
are displayed primarily
in various relationships
with parents, therefore
familial piety or familial duty,
which is another central
practice, of course,
in Confucius, and
loyalty generally.
Master You said--
Master You is one
of the disciples--
"few indeed are those
who are naturally filial
towards their
parents and dutiful
towards their elder
brothers but are also fond
of opposing their superiors.
And it never happens--
it never happens--
that those who
do not like opposing
their superiors
are fond of creating
civil disorder."
It's the kind of so-called
conservatism of Confucius.
"The gentleman concerns
himself with the root.
And if the root is firmly
planted, the Way grows.
Filial piety and fraternal
duty, surely they
are the roots of humaneness."
"The master said, young men
should be filial when at home
and respectful to elders
when away from home.
They should be earnest
and trustworthy.
Although they should love
the multitude far and wide,
they should be intimate
only with the humane."
I'll read one other.
"The Duke of Qi told Master
Kong, in my locality,
there's a certain paragon.
For when his father stole
a sheep, he, the son,
bore witness against him.
Master Kong said, in my
locality, those who are upright
are different from this.
Fathers cover up for their
sons, and sons cover up
for their fathers.
Uprightness is to
be found in this."
Yeah, and that can be compared
with a well-known dialogue
on piety of Plato's called
the Euthyphro, whose action
concerns this kind of thing.
It's not clear, I
think, from all this
that piety towards
one's father is
meant to be as complete
morally or as oppressive
as it seems to have become in
some later periods in China.
In loyalty, one also displays
other characteristics,
friendliness, honesty,
or trustworthiness.
Again, gentlemanly
or virtuous actions
are displayed and are connected
to these people and functions.
They're not merely,
for Confucius,
a general set of
qualities that follow
some sort of universal law.
As I said, Confucius
does not trace
the virtues and the qualities
to their intellectual roots.
They are recommended and, to
a degree, they're described.
But they're not really
defended philosophically.
Now, as I've said and
have just been saying,
the favored human types,
let's say the gentlemen,
the ones to which one aspires,
even if you can't quite
reach it, the
gentleman and the sage,
all of these practice virtuous
actions not abstractly
or as objects of
universal rules,
but rather they practice
them always within a context.
And the context-- and this
is really the next point.
The context is
primarily or directly
within ritual behavior
or customary ritual.
Li-- L-I-- is the term
that's usually translated
in one of those ways.
That's also connected to
reverence and courteous
behavior.
But it's not-- at least it
seems not to be in Confucius--
religious worship of
gods or direct concern
with an afterlife.
Where Confucius is on that
issue is a deep question
for those who study him.
Ritual behavior also
reflects and involves
refined and cultured behavior.
So to sum this up,
the central element
of Confucius's teaching,
what is central
is graciousness or propriety
in customary practices
and customary relations.
That really is kind of the
central substantive element
of Confucius's set of teachings.
To read again some
of that, Zhonggong
asked about humaneness.
"The master said, when you are
away from home, behave as if
receiving an important guest.
Employ the people as
if you were officiating
at a great sacrifice.
Do not impose on others what
you would not like yourself.
Then there will be no
resentment against you,
either in the state
or in the family.
Zhonggong said,
although I'm not clever,
I beg to put this
advice into practice."
Fan Chi, another disciple,
asked about humaneness.
"The master said, courtesy
in private life, reverence
in handling business, loyalty
and relations with others,
this should not be
set aside, even if one
visits the barbarian tribes."
Mm-hmm.
And a final one in this
group, Master Kong said,
"there are nine things the
gentleman concentrates on.
In seeing, he
concentrates on clarity.
In listening, he
concentrates on acuteness.
In expression, he
concentrates on warmness.
In demeanor, he
concentrates on courtesy.
In words, he
concentrates on loyalty.
In deeds, he concentrates
on reverence.
When he's in doubt,
he concentrates
on asking questions.
When he's indignant, he
concentrates on the problems--"
kind of the obstacles
which would slow you down,
slow down your indignity.
"And when he sees
opportunity for gain,
he concentrates
on what is right,"
a hard group of things, I think,
to actually do so completely.
Now, the next
point, all of this,
again let's call
it gentlemanliness
and humaneness, all
of this comes together
only with learning moral
and cultural, as well as,
to a degree, military and
mathematical learning.
"The master said, you have heard
the six sayings about the six
hidden consequences.
When he replied that he had not,
the master went on, sit down,
and I will tell you.
If one loves humaneness
but does not love learning,
the consequence
of this is folly.
If one loves understanding
but does not love learning,
the consequence of
this is unorthodoxy.
If one loves good faith
but does not love learning,
the consequence of this
is damaging behavior.
If one loves straightforwardness
but does not love learning,
the consequence of
this is rudeness.
If one loves courage but
does not love learning,
the consequence of
this is rebelliousness.
If one loves strength but
does not love learning,
the consequence of
this is violence."
So people can, of course
deviate from propriety.
They probably
usually do, in fact.
And Confucius's
interest, his concern
is to restore us to what he
thinks is the proper way.
This proper way,
he also indicates,
actually occurred earlier
in the reign of a Duke Zhou.
The perfect or best time,
as Confucius sees it,
is actually thought
of as something
which once concretely existed.
He doesn't project the kind
of impossible best government.
Rather, the best
government is something,
he claims, actually to
have existed in the past.
In fact, Confucius
thinks of himself
as a transmitter
not as a creator.
"The master said, I
transmit but do not create.
Being fond of the truth, I
am at admirer of antiquity."
"The master said, if by
keeping the old warm,
one can provide
understanding of the new.
One is fit to be a teacher."
That's a nice thought,
as so many of these are.
So one can see in all of
this that he exhorts us
to a way of life that
consists of proper behavior
in different activities
or functions or actions,
proper ways that emphasize
ritual and family
or filial piety, not
radical individualism.
And that points to virtuous
action, a little bit less
as character simply, and
more in terms of, again
gentlemanly propriety
and refinement,
even a kind of mannered
formalism in activity.
That's important for the
following reason for him.
You might wish to act
correctly, but what actually
is correct behavior
also depends on how
others understand what you're
doing and how you see them.
And that's one reason why
observing custom and ritual
can be important for
displaying proper respect.
This is from book 8,
chapter 2, "the master said,
if one is courteous but
does without ritual,
then one dissipates
one's energy.
If one is cautious but
does without ritual,
then one becomes timid.
If one is bold but
does without ritual,
then one becomes reckless.
If one is forthright
but does without ritual,
then one becomes rude."
Hence the need for
ritual to actually bring
about proper action,
whatever one's intention.
Because government,
politics, government,
is such an interest of ours,
let me discuss Confucius's views
on this further.
Confucius's sayings
on this are largely
about officials in government
and their behavior,
how they should act,
what their relations are.
Central is trust
and the similarity
between action in the family
and activity in government.
His remarks are not really
very much about institutions,
or even about justice
directly, but primarily
about behavior and action.
Let me read a few
things to give you
a sense of what his
views on this are.
"Duke Ding asked how rulers
should employ ministers
and how ministers
should serve rulers.
Master Kong replied, rulers
and employing ministers
do so in accordance with ritual.
And ministers, in serving
rulers, do so in accordance
with loyalty."
[? Zi Zhong ?] asked
about government.
"The master said, if
there's enough food,
and if there are enough
weapons, the people
will put their trust in it.
[? Zi Zhong ?] said,
suppose you definitely
had no alternative but to give
up one of these three, food,
weapons, trust, which
would you relinquish first?
The master said, I
would give up weapons.
[? Zi Zhong ?] said, suppose you
definitely had no alternative
but to give up one
of the remaining two,
which would you
relinquish first?
The master said, I
would give up food.
From of old, death
comes to all men.
But a people will not
stand if it lacks trust."
And then I'll read a
couple more on government.
"Zhonggong being
steward to the Ji family
asked about government.
The master said, give a
lead to your officials,
pardon minor errors, and promote
men of quality and talent.
He said, how does one recognize
men of quality and talent
so as to promote them?"
He said, "the master said,
promote those you do recognize,
for will others neglect
those you do not recognize?"
You can decide how
helpful that answer is.
[LAUGHTER]
And one more.
"Jikangzi asked,
how the people might
be induced to be
respectful and loyal,
so they might be
properly encouraged?
The master said, if you
oversee them with dignity,
they will be respectful.
If you're dutiful towards
your parents and kind
to your children, then
they will be loyal.
If you promote the good and
instruct the incompetent,
then they will be encouraged."
Let me now say
something very briefly
about the following question.
What, given all
this, could one say
about Confucius and
contemporary Chinese politics
and government?
During Mao's reign,
as I said, Confucius
was condemned as a reactionary.
But now the rulers
celebrate him.
As I said, they call
their institutes Confucian
institutes.
The question is, whether
or not Confucius's writings
are a force for individual
freedom, rights, privacy,
and independence.
He's certainly a force for
virtue, humaneness, learning,
trust, and friendship.
And in that sense, just
as Aristotle would be,
against tyranny,
Confucius favors
a kind of gentlemanliness.
Confucius also
distinguishes governments
that follow the right
way from those that
do not follow the right way.
Confucius also argues in
favor of the importance
of the proper alignment
of names and things,
the so-called
rectification of names,
of calling political and social
things what they actually are.
One might say he
opposes, in advance, some
of our political correctness.
Moreover, although humaneness
is practiced socially,
it's also ultimately in one's
own power to try to seek it.
But as I said, we do
not see in Confucius
the openness of individual
desire and satisfaction.
And there's a limit, which comes
from the great importance he
places on the kind of given
political and social roles.
So I would say, but
anyone could disagree,
that Confucius, the actual
Confucius of the Analects, is,
on the whole, healthy
or salutary force
for good politics,
but not simply.
Healthy because you
could not honestly
say that the current
leaders are expressing
proper Confucian qualities.
So I'll say a
couple more things,
and then we can
have some questions.
Confucius took many
characteristics seriously,
and he wanted them for himself.
And in many ways these
self understandings
are seen as exemplary
for other people as well.
"The master said, the failure
to cultivate virtue, the failure
to put it into
practice, the failure
to put into practice what I've
learned, hearing what is right
and being unable
to move towards it,
being unable to change
what's not good,
these are my worries."
"The master said,
in making an effort,
I am comparable with others.
But as to myself being
a gentleman in practice,
I have never yet managed
to achieve that."
[LAUGHTER]
"The master said, at 15, I
set my heart on learning.
At 30, I was established.
At 40.
I had no perplexities.
At 50, I understood
the decrees of heaven.
At 60, my ear was in accord.
And at 70, I followed what
my heart desired but did
not transgress what was right."
"The master said,
do I, for my part,
really possess understanding?
No, I do not possess
understanding.
But if there's an ordinary
person putting a question
to me, although his mind
seems to be quite blank,
I hammer at both
sides of the question
and go into it thoroughly."
Confucius also took music
and poetry very seriously
and the beauty connected to them
and the proper behavior that's
sometimes connected to them.
In this, he's like Plato.
But he doesn't think through, or
attempt even to think through,
universal characteristics by
which one could specify beauty.
I'll conclude with his
humor, or even his sarcasm,
and a couple of my
favorite sayings,
in addition to the
ones I've read.
"Ji Wen-zi thought three
times before acting.
When the master heard of this
he said, twice will be enough."
[LAUGHTER]
And a couple of others.
"The master said, if a man
does not anticipate deception
and does not reckon on bad
faith, but on the other hand,
is aware in good time when they
occur, he is a man of quality,
isn't he?"
And then finally, 2, 17,
"the master said, You--"
this is one of the disciples,
whose nickname is You--
"You, shall I teach you about
understanding something?
When you understand
something, to recognize
that you understand it.
But when you do not
understand something,
to recognize that you
do not understand it.
That is understanding."
[LAUGHTER]
And then actually this
is the final one now
because I can't resist this,
especially in this context.
"The master said, it
is not easy to find
anyone who studies
for three years
but is not intent on a salary."
[LAUGHTER]
So that's Confucius
in a nutshell.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
NATALIE KENT: Thank
you, Dr. Blitz.
We now have time
for a few questions.
Please make your way
to the microphone,
if you have a question.
AUDIENCE: Aristotle
was the one that
discovered man's mind and
reason and understanding
the world that way.
Aren't you giving
Confucius too much credit
by comparing him to Aristotle?
Because Aristotle is unique in
the known history of the world.
MARK BLITZ: I try
to lay out some
of the differences between
Aristotle and Confucius.
The grounds of comparison come
from the relative similarity
in time--
Confucius is older-- and
the listing of the virtues
and the listing of the human
qualities and the thinking
through of those qualities.
That's really the substance
of the comparison.
But in a way, it's precisely
the philosophical underpinnings
that you don't see in
Confucius and the full working
out of the various
dimensions and possibilities
of the virtues,
happiness, and so on.
So I think I'm giving
Aristotle his proper rank.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned the--
over here.
Over here.
MARK BLITZ: I see.
AUDIENCE: Exit stage
right, or something.
You had mentioned that
during Mao's time,
he tried to eliminate
references to Confucius.
Of course there was the
famous Little Red Book of Mao
during the Cultural Revolution.
In your knowledge
of Confucius, do you
know whether any of
his particular sayings
were plagiarized by Mao?
MARK BLITZ: No, I
don't know concretely.
But I wouldn't be surprised.
Mao also, in the
condemnation of Confucius,
had everyone read
Confucius to see
all the things that were wrong,
which was maybe not so wise.
And the new group is wiser about
those matters, I would say.
But I would really have to look
carefully at The Little Red
Book and other works of
Mao to answer that question
concretely.
AUDIENCE: So speaking
of the new regime
and how they've more
or less capitulated
to the cultural history
of Confucianism,
give me insights on how they've
managed to sort of round
the square peg
there around stuff
like, for example,
calling it like it is.
Stuff like that's not very
common with Soviet-style
totalitarian communist regimes.
MARK BLITZ: There
is this element
in Confucius, where you act
as you should in relation
to the role that you have.
Confucius is not revolutionary.
He's not radical, really, in
his thinking, and even the way
that, let's say, Plato is.
So I think this you can work
with elements in Confucius
in a useful way.
But in the long run, if people
take Confucius seriously,
they will see the difference
between the government
they have and the
virtues that are
being suggested by Confucius.
So there's a lot of
material that you
can work with in sort of
incorporating Confucius
into your argument
and your propaganda.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you for your speech today.
Would you say that
the current regime
has tried to capture
Confucianism,
the way that the left here in
America is captured as liberal?
I, even here, can
see conservatives
speak about the left as if they
deserved the title liberal.
And I'm wondering if you
could make that comparison?
MARK BLITZ: For a
while, the general kind
of category for our regime is
indeed a liberal democracy.
So it's not accurate,
right, as you're
suggesting, for Liberalism,
in the true sense,
to be captured by the left.
And even the left of this
kind of left-right divide,
which kind of became formal, in
a way, in the 1820s or 1830s,
the liberal element there was a
pro-business and pro-parliament
element.
So, yeah, there is something
wrong about the way in which we
talk about our
politics, for sure.
Yes, I think the goal
of the current regime--
and I think that's true of, in
a way, any thoughtful regime,
is to try to have behind you
as much as you can that you
think the people won't give up.
So radical as you
might be, it may often
be the case that you
want to show elements
of what you're doing as
continuous with what's
been there in the past.
How successful they'll
be, I don't know.
That would be a prediction
that would be hard to make.
So we'll see.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
weapons, so I know
Confucius thought about it.
Could you share some
sayings on his ideas
about war and conflict?
MARK BLITZ: So archery
is one of the things
that you're supposed to study.
Confucius was not ultimately
that interested in war.
He's not really, I think,
where you'd look for strategy,
as there are, of course, other
great works that you look at.
It's secondary always to
virtue, you might say.
Confucius is not
against punishment.
But punishment is
secondary to virtue also.
It shouldn't be necessary.
So Confucius is more in that
direction and not so much
in the direction of
war and conflict.
Harmony would come
closer to what he might
desire than conflict would.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
pacifist [INAUDIBLE]??
MARK BLITZ: No, he's
certainly not a pacifist.
And he, himself,
engaged in certain kind
of political activities.
He's not a pacifist.
But war is not his
favorite option.
There are a lot of
wars then, though.
You needed to fight in
order to preserve yourself
and to preserve your dynasty.
So pacifism, no, but war as
something desirable, not much.
Courage is one of the
virtues, but it's not
one that goes all that far by
itself either, but certainly
not pacifism.
AUDIENCE: Probably like
many of us here in the room,
I graduated from college in '69.
And Chairman Mao's Little Red
Book was kind of everywhere,
even though I was on a
relatively safe campus,
so to speak.
And I wasn't reminded
of that until one
of Obama's initial
appointees declared
that Mao and Mother Teresa
were her favorite philosophers.
And is there anyone outside of
people in Berkeley and Harvard
who think of Mao
as a philosopher?
Is he venerated in his
country, or are they
trying to discredit him?
MARK BLITZ: We'll leave
Mother Teresa out of it.
Yeah, I would say
a lot of this has
to do with the
relative power of China
and the resurgence of
that kind of activity
and that kind of politics.
There are fewer direct
Maoists than there were
in the late '60s, early '70s.
But there's still, I
think, a serious strain
among certain people
of a kind of Maoism.
But how far something
like that will go
depends very much
on what happens,
I think, in China itself.
I don't come across,
even the colleagues
of whom I'm not that fond,
dancing up and down to tell me
how wonderful Mao is.
But of course, I
would not be the one
in front of whom they'd
perform such a dance.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Good evening, sir.
Thank you so much for coming
to Hillsdale this evening
for your discussion.
In Steven Mosher's
book, The Bully of Asia,
he draws attention to a comment
from Confucius that reads,
"just as there are not
two suns in the sky,
so there cannot be two
emperors on Earth."
And he ties it into
ancient Chinese history.
My question for you is,
as you understand him,
does Confucian teaching endorse
the ambitions of conquest
by brute force, as done
from the great unification
to the disputes
with the West today?
MARK BLITZ: Steven
Mosher will speak to you.
So you can see what he says.
I would say no.
He doesn't endorse
conquest by brute force
because his goals are not
really served by brute force.
But his picture of
the best government
was what you can consider a
whole empire over the territory
that he knew best.
It didn't really function
that way when he was alive.
And who knows whether it ever
really functioned that way.
But that was the government
that he liked best.
So that there might be a
single empire over the known
territory, could well be.
If that needed to be
brought about by force,
one way or the other, perhaps,
but not something, I think,
that he would want to be
kept in place by force, kept
in place by fear, but rather
by these other qualities
he's discussing.
AUDIENCE: Thank you, sir.
MARK BLITZ: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Confucius
would have been
approximately a contemporary
of the prophet Daniel
from the Old Testament.
And Daniel would have had known
the history of the Hebrews,
of course, and he
studied the Chaldeans.
I just wondered whether you
are aware of any connection
educationally, whether
Confucius could have
gotten his ideas about virtue--
and the principle
underpinnings of him
seem to have a lot of parallels
with biblical history.
And I just wonder if
you could address that.
Thank you.
MARK BLITZ: Well, I'm not
aware of any direct connection.
And it would be
difficult because
of the kind of isolation of
these places from each other.
There are various arguments
to the effect that and which
find it very
interesting that you
have so many movements in
religion and even philosophy
more or less around
the same time, making
somewhat similar statements.
But I doubt that there would
be any direct connection.
But one can never say never.
But none that I'm aware of.
And I would doubt it, given the
range of things that Confucius
knew of or didn't know
of, given he traveled,
but the travel is
obviously limited.
So you would have to find
something that somehow came
and that he saw.
And I think that's
not all that likely.
A lot of his thought,
of course, resonates
with things in the past.
But some of it is novel as well.
So that would be my view.
But those things are always
subject to new discovery.
NATALIE KENT: Thank
you Dr. Blitz.
MARK BLITZ: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]